please welcome Academy Award nominee
Sigourney Weaver
you know when I first arrived on the set
of alien at Shepperton Studios I was
blown away by the beauty of the sets and
I used to kind of wander around between
takes thinking this is so nice of the
filmmakers to construct these huge
beautiful sets just for the actors then
the aliens arrived and destroyed
everything luckily we captured her on
film
this year's art direction candidates are
particularly talented and exhibit a
staggering range here are the nominees
for outstanding art direction avatar
production designed by Rick Carter and
Robert Stromberg set decoration by Kim
Sinclair The Imaginarium of Doctor
Parnassus production designed by Dave
Warren and honest Asia bizarro set
decoration by Caroline Smith 9
production designed by John Mayer and
set decoration by Gordon sim Sherlock
Holmes production designed by Sarah
Greenwood and set decoration by Katie
Spencer
the young victoria production designed
by Patrice Vermette and set decoration
by Maggie gray and the winner is avatar
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Rick Carter and
Robert Stromberg this is the first Oscar
and nomination for Kim's and Claire
Jim Cameron this this Oscar sees you
clearly your vision is so deep
you know 13 years ago doctors told me I
wasn't going to survive and I thought
that this dream of standing here would
never come true and here we are I owe
this to my amazing wife Liz my two kids
recent Remmy for supporting me Brook
Bretton Rick Carter and the hundreds of
people that it took to make this film
thank you
special thanks to John Landau Jim every
day we went to work
we knew we were working with the genius
we really work we all felt that thank
you so much
you